>> You see this in a situation where you may have a 4000 pixel by 4000 pixel
texture that may be fetched from a server. This single fetch can take about 241
milliseconds to download, which is actually pretty fast. If you were actually to
chop up that image into smaller little pixels, so, for example, we would create
4,000 separate images, the total load time to request all of those images to
occupy the same amount of space would change drastically. In fact, it would
actually increase from 241 milliseconds to 4.3 seconds, that's an increase of 17
times. With this in mind, it makes sense then that in order to reduce load times
for high performance web applications, we should group as many of the small
elements together into one large image to reduce the number HTTP requests. This
process of packing smaller images into larger images is known as texture
atlasing and is a very well-studied process in most games. For example, in
real-time graphics, a texture atlas is a single large image that contains many
smaller sub-images, each of which can be referenced independently.